[Musique]
il y a quelques jours à Roanne une
affaire avait fait la une des médias un
père de famille qui s'est fait justice
lui-même selon ce père de famille un
adolescent serait entré dans son
domicile dans la nuit ce sera trop dû
chez lui et aurait agressé sexuellement
sa fille de 6 ans après avoir effectué
des rondes de surveillance le père de la
petite fille et ses amis finissent par
retrouver le jeûne et décide de lui
asséner des coups de pieds de points de
barre de fer et de câble électrique on a
réussi à le canaliser après voilà les
petits étaient dans une rage folle enfin
que c'est logique c'est logique de son
côté le mineur a nié les faits et
apporter plein de contre eux une enquête
a été ouverte pour violence en réunion
avec armes vengeance d'un père à Roanne
comprenez vous que le père en cours
finalement de la prison ferme
merci merci d'être avec nous David
Metaxas vous êtes l'un des avocats d'un
des mises en cause merci d'être là merci
David bonsoir venez nous voir souvent et
là c'est vrai que vous allez nous
éclairer sur cette affaire qui fait
énormément parler comprenez vous que le
père en cours finalement de la prison
ferme l'histoire commence il y a une
dizaine de jours à 3h du matin un jeune
de 16 ans pénètre dans un pavillon il
entre dans la chambre de la petite fille
de 6 ans et ça donne à des attouchements
de nature sexuelle la mer seul dans le
logement avec ses enfants se réveillent
entre dans la chambre et voit le jeune
homme elle hurle et le jeune homme
s'enfuit le lendemain le père de
l'enfant raconte qu'il s'est ce qui
s'est passé assez avec ses voisins à ses
voisins et ensemble il décide donc des
films d'effectuer des surveillances dans
le quartier on a vu la noire qui était
celui qui avait retrouvé le jeune homme
il tombe sur ce jeune homme il le
maîtrise le prenne en photo ils vont
alors
le poursuivre et
le frapper sur les informations de BFM
TV le réfrappé à coup de pied de barre
de fer et de câble électrique c'est
parce qu'on nous a dit boulanoua qui est
venu nous voir la semaine dernière une
fois la police sur place le garçon et
conduit à l'hôpital où il aura 10 jours
d'été alors l'adolescent était placé en
garde à vue puis mise en examen est
placé en détention provisoire il s'agit
d'un mineur isolé arrivée en France le
mois dernier il conteste l'effet pour
ses fils pour encourir jusqu'à 10 ans de
prison et il apportait plainte contre le
papa de la victime
aujourd'hui comprenez-vous que le père
en cours finalement de la prison ferme
beaucoup ne comprennent pas Gilles
Verdez vous vous comprenez oui parce que
le père donc a été placé en garde à vue
il a reconnu les faits le procureur
avait donné le ton en disant on ne se
fait pas justice soi-même et comme le
père reconnaît les filles il sera jugé
en janvier au tribunal et Cyril là où on
peut vraiment discuter c'est qu'il
risque de très longue peine puisque ben
oui puisqu'il risque au moins 7 ans de
prison puisque ce sera pour violence en
réunion avec armes par destination il
t'était le plus de huit jours c'est des
circonstances aggravantes c'est de voir
neuf ans de prison et comme le père a un
casier judiciaire franchement la
sanction risque d'être très très lourde
donc moi je comprends qu'il aille en
prison mais pas pour 7 ou 9 ans mais une
peine de prison ferme vu l'affaire ça ne
me semble pas illogique parce qu'on ne
peut pas rendre soi-même
le père pour moi aurait dû interpeller
il l'avait entre leurs mains la maman
avait reconnu la photo interpellée
appelez la police tout de suite ils
l'ont appelé après l'avoir tabassé pour
moi il ne fallait pas tabasser il
fallait appeler la police tout de suite
alors on va avoir des infos dans un
instant avec David Metaxas l'avocat d'un
des protagonistes Delphine pour toi
c'est non
par exemple dans une cour de récré on
dit qui a commencé est-ce que ce père il
voulait que un gars rentre et fasse des
attouchements sur sa fille enfin Gilles
vous rendez compte que c'est pas ça
va basculer la vie de sa famille la vie
de sa fille la vie de sa femme ça
basculer alors qu'il a rien demandé
c'est aussi il a rien demandé et
j'aimerais vraiment beaucoup qu'un jour
du pont Moretti viennent ici pour nous
expliquer en fait comment fonctionne la
justice française ça me fait penser aux
bijoutiers qui s'est fait braquer et au
final il s'est défendu et au final le
gars est en prison maintenant c'est
n'importe quoi c'est le monde à l'envers
et ça continue ça divers en fait divers
alors Béatrice
je comprends pas du tout aujourd'hui
j'ai allumé les infos il y avait
l'histoire d'une femme qui a failli
presque être tuée par un cambrioleur et
il avait fait déjà deux autres
cambriolages la même soirée et il a
écopé d'un an avec sursis et là on nous
dit que quelqu'un qui défend sa fille de
6 ans 6 ans sur laquelle il y a eu des
des une agression actuelle il va partir
en prison pour plus longtemps que
quelqu'un qui a failli tuer on marche
sur la tête la justice marche sur la
tête vraiment on n'en peut plus et c'est
un symptôme et c'est pas voilà il faut
il faut régler le problème de la justice
en France il y a un vrai problème non
moi ce que j'entends ce que tu dis
évidemment il y a cette forte émotion
mais étant sûr que c'est vraiment ce
jeune homme on n'est pas sûr de ça non
non on n'est pas sûr il est présumé
innocent oui désolé c'est très important
dans toute cette
fois après avec vous pouvez nous dire ça
vous pouvez juste nous dire ah non mais
il y a une certitude une conviction de
certitude c'est que c'est lui voilà il y
a une certitude c'est lui
il est identifié par la mère qui s'est
retrouvé nez à nez avec lui dans le
couloir à la sortie de la chambre de sa
fille et il porte si ça suffisait pas le
même t-shirt que la veille donc il est
formé le mot identifié et mieux que ça
cirait et je crois que ça c'est pas
assez aborder qu'est-ce qu'il foutait ce
gamin-là au même endroit à la même heure
que la veille
et de ses amis ils se sont demandés s'il
allait pas recommencer bien sûr mais
c'est ça et là ça change tout on est
plus du tout dans une histoire vengeance
là on est dans une histoire de légitime
défense de la petite parce que si les
retourne dans la chambre après avoir
fait ça on fait comment vis-à-vis de la
gamine c'est ça le vrai débat que pose
cette affaire et si ils l'ont interpellé
ils en ont le droit c'est prévu par la
loi il y a un article l'article 73 du
code qui dit en cas de délit ou de crime
flagrant
tout donne pas Pauline ça c'est
intéressant toute personne ton citoyen a
le droit d'interpeller une personne la
seule obligation qu'elle est par la
suite et ça c'est Monsieur Verdez
effectivement qu'il expliquait c'est
d'avertir les autorités judiciaires tout
de suite mais ils avaient le droit de
l'interpeller ce garçon a raison de ce
qu'il avait fait la veille et a raison
de ce qu'on pouvait le soupçonner de
vouloir récidiver exactement alors on va
revenir sur la terre dans un instant
reste avec nous il est 20h56 on en
dirait que vous allez nous raconter ça
parce que vous êtes un des avocats de
celui qui a donc attrapé le présumé
coupable voilà et vous nous dites donc
vers la montée après avoir entendu ça
parce que déjà vous partiez d'un
postulat faux donc je reprenais tout
mais il est évident il est évident que
quand on vit un truc pareil on puisse
réagir comme ça seulement alors dans ces
cas-là moi je reviens à l'état de droit
ça va être très compliqué maintenant
appeler la police d'accord mais mais pas
le tabasser avant si vous voulez on
prend le mec et on le fil à la police et
puis voilà c'est ça que je reproche
c'est qu'il a été il a été tabassé très
violemment non mais après c'est la
justice de faire ça
très violemment comme il l'a été mais je
comprends la haine évidemment
c'est pas de la haine c'est simplement
qu'on a assez un gamin qui se refait
prendre la main dans le sac pour pas
dire dans la culotte de la petite hein
six ans main dans la culotte hein
non non mais attendez là je suis pas en
train de faire une plaisanterie on est
sur une tentative de viol d'une mineur
âgé de 6 ans dans son domicile en pleine
nuit c'est ça que le père a voulu éviter
et les copains sont mobilisés parce que
la petite il adore tous ils n'ont pensé
qu'à la petite et à son intégrité
physique et sexuelle et c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont décidé à la place de la
police de faire une mesure de protection
de surveillance et comme par hasard le
lendemain il retombe sur lui et là ils
ont décidé de l'interpeller alors
justement qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
interpeller parce que toi Bernard tu te
dis quelqu'un rentre chez toi tu lui dis
excusez-moi monsieur est-ce que vous
pouvez vous mettre de côté le temps que
j'appelle la police
[Applaudissements]
qui est très douloureuse et épouvantable
mauvais esprits
tu fais quoi toi
qui qui est agressif qui est violent qui
ont plus de ça chez toi tu fais quoi il
était armé non parce que dans ce cas là
je pense qu'il faut se mettre à la place
d'un père de famille je comprends mais
on peut pas faire sa place d'un père de
famille et c'est
ce que tout le monde pense je le vois
sur les réseaux là tout le monde se dit
on se met à la place d'un père de
famille bien sûr imaginons que ça nous
arrive imaginons et imaginons le mec
revient le lendemain en plus c'est
incroyable tu te dis c'est c'est fou
donc franchement c'est incroyable alors
ceux qui disent oui Raymond alors je
suis très étonné
non je bouge pas moi je tourne pas les
pancartes parce que j'ai besoin des
pancartes pour tourner je tourne pas les
pancartes moi le soir quand je vous ai
raconté on m'a dit on n'est pas dans
X-Files je bouge pas aujourd'hui tu peux
pas aller dans la rue et taper quelqu'un
et rouler de coup quelqu'un au risque de
le blesser vous savez très bien moi mais
bon si tu es content de 2 minutes juste
si c'est encore pour nous dire ton truc
et c'est peut-être pas le mec et tout ça
là on a du principe que c'est le gars
mais la justice moi ma justice à moi
j'aimerais bien que d'un homme s'occupe
du mec non mais c'est pas ça parce que
ce que dit Gilles il a il aurait dû et
ça c'est vrai que c'est ce que l'on dit
l'interpeller et appeler la police et le
mettre voilà le truc mais ton truc ça
fait 15 fois qu'on l'entend non je veux
à 100 %. ça fait 15 fois mais je veux
dire une 16e fois je veux être sûr à
100% que ce soit ce mec-là si ça se met
là moi j'ai pas de j'ai pas de sous j'ai
pas de souci avec tu ne sors de la
société tu le vire je vous ai déjà dit
je vais pas redire le mot je l'ai déjà
dit maintenant j'aimerais bien qu'on
juge d'abord le mec voir trouver ses
empreintes être sûr à 100% de chez lui
et si c'est lui à 100% et pas un
quelqu'un qu'on a vu dans la pénombre
quelqu'un qui s'est sauvé si c'est lui à
100% qu'il plonge et ainsi ils prennent
30 ans qu'ils prennent 40 ans
il faut qu'on fasse ce qu'on en veut je
m'en fous
le père c'est que le père n'aille pas en
prison d'abord il faut d'abord juger le
le le tromper le papa il faut le laisser
pour l'instant
il faut déjà juger la personne qui a
commis l'effet ben c'est ce que je veux
dire la personne qui a commis les faits
dès qu'on a ses empreintes dès qu'on
sait que c'est lui sans il paye il paye
le prix fort le prix le plus fort
maintenant il est en cours parce que moi
je veux me défendre je veux pas demain
il y a des mecs qui tapent les gens
n'importe comment dans la rue c'est pas
ça c'est pas ça c'est pas ça la justice
maintenant c'est pas ça va se retrouver
dans la rue écoute ce qu'on dit là parce
que là non mais écoute ce que là tu pars
tu écoutes même pas ce qui se passe
rien mais écoute ce qui se dit parce que
tu parles dans des dans des délires elle
a passé parce qu'elle a dit on part on
parle juste d'un principe c'est que
d'abord c'est vrai qu'il faut d'abord
peut-être juger la personne exactement
c'est normal qu'il faut faire aussi une
enquête sur sur ce qui s'est passé avec
le papa de la petite et ses amis
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé exactement en
fait tous les points de vue sont en
tandem moi franchement je suis sensible
aux sensibilités qui s'exprime mais il
faut voir aussi parce que c'est facile
avec du recul sur un plateau de télé de
dire il faut que ce suspect là celui de
la tentative de viol soit jugé avec les
grands principes d'un procédé
démocratique on est tous d'accord pour
ça société civilisée eux ils sont à
quelques heures de ce qui vient de se
passer on est à chaud il tombe sur lui
je crois qu'ils sont les premiers
surpris de le recroiser au même endroit
dans leur tête ça explose dans la tête
du père ça explose parce qu'il se dit il
est là pour recommencer c'est quelqu'un
qui non seulement n'a pas peur mais qui
revient ça c'est extrêmement rare et
puis les les complices du père ce sont
des oncles ils sont considérés comme des
autres justement on a eu 10 jours d’été
c'est pas énorme 10 jours
c'est beaucoup euh si c'est
médical également constaté c'est
beaucoup mais mais ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que on a affaire aussi à quelqu'un
a priori de jeûne on a même un doute sur
son état civil eux ils sont persuadés
qu'il était pas mineur lui dit qu'il
était mineur c'est ça rend les choses
très compliquées mais on a une ité qui
est conséquente d'accord mais c'est
parce qu'il s'est débattu alors
il s'est débattu et donc eux pour le
maîtriser et voilà ils ont utilisé des
moyens de contorsion c'est très clair
les policiers disent avoir assisté à une
scène de violence bon les policiers
manifestement ça les a pas choqués parce
que sur le moment c'est pas du tout ce
qui dit et les policiers ils ont bien
ils ont hyper bien fait leur travail
c'est pas la question
qu'ils ont embarqué c'est pas ceux qui
violentaient bien sûr les policiers sont
compris ils ont compris la situation
et c'est ce que j'espère que les juges
vont faire aussi parce que les juges ont
l'air d'être sensible ils auraient pu
être traduits en comparaison immédiate
dès vendredi dernier là il passe avec
une date de convocation on a un peu de
temps c'est le 24 janvier ça apaise les
tensions du quartier aussi il faut des
pètes qu'est-ce qu'il encouragent alors
parce que vous êtes un des avocats ils
ont encore beaucoup ils ont combien ils
ont cours pour ceux qui n'ont pas
d'antécédents qui sont pas en récidive
cette année pour ceux qui le sont 14
années d'emprisonnement donc c'est
conséquent
bien c'est les peines prévues dans le
code et c'est sûr maximale ils vont pas
prendre ça nous l'objectif c'est qu'il
reste en liberté mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut milkside doit accepter parce qu'ils
ont dit qu'on qu'ils avaient réagi à
chaud qui regrettaient ce qu'ils avaient
fait donc ils vont accepter le principe
d'une condamnation par contre ces
individus là le père c'est qu'on puisse
ils ont strictement rien à faire en
détention mais ça moi je peux pas le
concevoir et j'espère que les juges ils
sont sensibles un procureur fait un
discours de force et la raison il veut
ramener l'ordre public à Roanne mais
mais voilà après il faut prendre le
contexte il y a des faits
évidemment et puis c'est des regrets
sincères c'est des gens vous disiez tout
à l'heure Cyril c'est des gens qui n'ont
pas demandé à être là oui c'est des gens
qui n'ont rien demandé à personne et
sont des gens qui sont mis en protecteur
d'une gamine de 6 ans qui venait de se
faire agresser sexuellement à son
domicile
quelle paire de famille n'aurait pas eu
la même réaction que ces gammes
je pose la question si les magistrats
ont des enfants et moi je veux les
mettre en face de cela alors ils doivent
comprendre parce que encore une fois
c'est facile avec du recul de dire oui
il faut un procès faut un procès mais
quand il s'agit de la chair de sa chair
quand il s'agit de son enfant qui vient
d'être agressé sur le point d'être à
nouveau agressé toutes les barrières
tombent et c'est ce qui s'est passé pour
ces hommes là
vous avez tout dit c'est un père c'est
un père et encore et excuse-moi mais
c'est pas une milice tu vois de
d'inconnu qui fait des rondes dans la
ville et qui prend un mec qui ont
accepté lui et qu'il bastonne c'est un
père qui reste mais on va pas ici on
n'est pas là pour discuter d'abord
pour dire mais pas là pour dire si il y
a la loi pas la loi on est là pour dire
est-ce que la réaction d'un père avec ce
qu'il a vécu est-ce que vous la
comprenez moi je la comprends après on
peut on peut parler des heures sur la
loi et c'est la loi et si ce mec-là va
sept ans en tôle c'est un pur scandale
c'est inadmissible faut pas qu'il non
mais non c'est inadmissible c'est pas
possible et c'est pas des mecs qui sont
partis en mini c'est 14 ans faire des
bastonner au hasard
la question c'est un père est-ce qu'on
comprend ce père moi qui quoi qu'il est
fait avant je le comprends s'il y a
quelqu'un rends dans la chambre de mon
fils qui a 3 ans qu'elle avec la main
dans ce slip crois-moi si je tombe
dessus
arrêtez de disserter sur le lendemain
d'un père et le père moi je comprends sa
réaction et c'est pas une milice c'est
pas un mec au hasard c'est un papa
tolérable juste Guillaume toi tu
comprends qu'il puisse prendre après je
pense qu'on va pas ressentir ce que ce
père a ressenti tant qu'on l'a pas vécu
évidemment donc on peut pas juger de sa
réaction néanmoins ce qu'il a fait il
l'a fait et ne pas le condamner quelque
part c'est cautionner le fait de se
faire justice soi-même c'est cautionner
aussi la loi du plus fort et ça veut
dire qu'après il y a plus de limite et
moi j'ai une question on avait lu dans
les tous premiers articles qu'on l'a
fait quand le scandale a éclaté que si
les policiers n'étaient pas arrivés le
jeune homme serait mort est-ce que c'est
vrai par exemple non ça c'est absolument
faux c'est ce qu'on a lu au début qui a
appelé les services de police c'est le
c'est de la famille c'est proche donc le
but c'était pas du tout de le séquestrer
de le garder longtemps c'est eux-mêmes
qui ont appelé les services de police
pour qu'ils interviennent quand je vous
dis qu'ils ont mis en application à leur
façon à texte de loi c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont interpellé
l'individu et après ils ont appelé le
service de police il y a cette phase
de laquelle ils vont devoir répondre
c'est une évidence et ça c'est de
l'excès c'est de l'excès mais c'est de
l'excès qui se justifie parce qu'ils ont
pu ressentir et par le fait qu'on avait
encore une fois un individu qui voulait
tout sauf rester sur place en situation
irrégulière j'ai au minimum de 16 ans
dans un foyer qui continuait à tourner
là et qui n'avait qu'une envie c'était
de la prendre la poudre d'escampette il
est
incarcérés bien et c'est individu est en
prison
revenir sur l'affaire il est 21h07 on
est en direct David Metaxas de quoi
votre client est-il exactement accusé
aujourd'hui
les accusations sont assez lourdes parce
que les services de police les deux
fonctionnaires de police sur place
disent qu'ils l'ont identifié comme
étant l'un des individus porteurs d'une
arme notamment à câble électrique
mon client lui proteste il dit moi
j'étais présent mais j'ai pas frappé et
il dit d'ailleurs vous pourrez voir sur
les caméras de vidéos surveillance de la
ville ou sur les caméras de vidéos que
portaient les services de police et
alors là comme par hasard ils étaient
deux fonctionnaires porteurs dans leur
caméra en état de marche elles n'ont
rien enregistré oui mais bon ça pourquoi
quel est
pourquoi il ferait ça
et la vidéo va le montrer lui papa
savoir que les caméras a fonctionnent
pas et il est sûr de lui parce que on
aurait pu le filmer en train de faire
des violences et là les policiers nous
disent ah bah non on a rien comment il
s'est retrouvé dans cette affaire
c'est le meilleur ami du père d'accord
il appelle un casier
il appelle pas pour violence il appelle
la petite ma princesse elle l'appelle
tonton donc il était il était furieux ah
il était plus que furieux donc il a il a
il dit qu'il a pas tapé lui lui il a été
appelé par le père en plus en dernier
lorsque le père lui a dit on tient en
fait après que le père est identifié les
photos et donc ouais il est arrivé il
était il le dit dans un état fou furieux
et la question qui se sont tous posées
c'est de dire aux gars mais qu'est-ce
que tu fais encore ici c'est ça pourquoi
t'es revenu et il est pas revenu pour
voler hein il est revenu au même endroit
vous disiez tout à l'heure ils l'ont pas
interpellé dans la chambre ils l'ont
interpellé devant la porte d'entrée
c'est le père qui a reconnu les photos
ouais parce que nous ils nous ont dit
ici que c'était la merde le père avec la
mère qui a gagné la photo
pas de problème il risque une peine de
prison lourde après c'est pas de la
flagornerie mais je connais les
magistrats surtout dans ce genre
d'affaires ils vont prendre en contexte
en considération par dans le contexte je
suis convaincu moi que le principe dans
cette affaire c'est celui de la liberté
pour ses individus ils vont rester en
liberté ils vont être condamnés mais il
y a plein de peine alternatives du
sursis du souci avec nous à l'épreuve du
suivi socio-judiciaire mais encore une
fois ces garçons ne doivent pas leur
donner ils doivent pas y aller
aujourd'hui
en tant qu'avocat est-ce que vous
condamnez leurs gestes ou est-ce que
vous comprenez leur geste tout dépend à
qui on pose la question moi je vais pas
mentir vous êtes père de famille et oui
si on pose la question perd de famille
je vais utiliser le devoir de réserve
mais franchement je suis fier de les
défendre je vais le dire je vais le dire
comme ça si on pose la question à
l'auxiliaire de justice on vit dans une
société civilisée les procès sont faits
pour ça pour qu'on puisse attaquer
quelqu'un ou se défendre et Monsieur
vous n'avez pas tort évidemment que ce
gamin il a encore la présomption
d'innocence a raison du crime qu'il a
commis mais voilà l'avocat dit non c'est
pas bien
dit je peux comprendre la justice ça
peut pas être rendue de cette manière
si profondément humaine la justice
soi-même
il y a des cas il y a des cas
médiatiques où on a vu on a vu des pères
venger leur fils l'affaire Vima on a vu
ça celui qui est allé chercher le
docteur en Allemagne pour venger le le
l'assassinat de sa gamine et les juges
on prend en considération le contexte
c'est interdit mais les peines sont pas
du tout ce qu'elles devraient être dans
des cas plus normaux donc ils prennent
en considération ça qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit de cette
affaire il y a du coup elle producteur
pour l'instant il est il est remonté
mais le procureur il est responsable de
l'ordre public à Roanne bien sûr et on
est dans un petit quartier vous savez
quand ils sont sortis du Palais de
Justice ces trois garçons vendredi quand
ils ont été libérés il y avait une haie
d'honneur une centaine de jeunes qui ont
applaudi la libération de ces gamins
pour dire je dis ces gamins parce que
c'est des jeunes et en fait pour dire
qu'en réalité les gens les soutiennent
il y a tout un quartier qui se
mobilisent pour le procureur a pris
conscience de ça donc le procureur a
fait un discours ferme mais a permis
quand même parce que c'est procureur qui
a pris cette décision que ces gamins
ressortent pour être jugé bien plus tard
bien sûr c'est vrai qu'il aurait été
reproché aussi de parler dans les médias
notamment à bout la noire c'est jamais
simple ah oui c'est jamais ça qui se
pose encore la question ils sont très
sollicités bien sûr savoir s'ils doivent
le faire ou pas avocat on a plutôt
tendance à conseiller d'éviter de le
faire parce que c'est toujours difficile
de rattraper à propos malheureux mais
mais oui ils sont sollicités ils le
feront et je sais que où la noire qui
était qui était venu la semaine dernière
qui était dans l'affaire c'est lui qui a
reconnu c'est lui qui a repéré le le
jeune homme lui on lui a reprochait
d'avoir parlé dans les médias bien sûr
c'est mal perçu ah oui pourquoi c'est
mal perçu parce que
le fait que quelqu'un qui à l'aune de
son jugement prenne position dans la
presse surtout quand on a leur parcours
leur personnalité c'est pas forcément
bien interprété par les magistrats moi
je considère que c'est une bonne chose
parce que ce genre d'affaires mérite
d'être mise sur la place
c'est pas c'est pas l'opinion publique
qui juges mais quand même ça montre
l'émotion que ça a suscité et le fait
que les gens les soutiennent parce que
les gens les soutiennent sur les réseaux
dans les médias ça c'est quelque chose
de force c'est un message aussi envoyé
au magistrats pour dire attendez prenez
en compte l'agression du départ pour
finalement juger ses hommes là c'est
quoi les profils alors des des profils
c'est dur ce que je veux dire parce que
tous les jeunes de quartier sont pas
comme ça mais des jeunes de quartiers à
la base c'est comme ça qui se
connaissent ils ont toujours évolué dans
le même environnement et c'est vrai
qu'il y a des casiers il y a des casiers
c'est pas des on a vu pire quoi c'est
pas des des tueurs en série il y a
évidemment aucune condamnation de nature
sexuelle c'est des casiers de vol bien
souvent des choses comme ça bon qui
remonte par rapport avec ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui aucun rapport la
violence en réunion
peut-être mais moi je connais pas tous
les casiers peut-être pour un mais pas
pour le mien pas pour le bien des voilà
gravés
pas de tourner à 2h du matin pour
essayer de retrouver un agresseur pour
protéger la petite et c'est des gens qui
ont été mis en face d'une situation ils
ont eu du mal à gérer on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le papa il fait ça très
difficilement il paraît qu'ils ont prévu
peut-être même de déménager ces
catastrophique pour eux c'est c'est
important que le café se mobilise parce
que ça les aide les voisins sont
présents ils sont allés les chercher au
palais de justice mais oui tout ça bah
ça les met ça les confronte une nouvelle
fois à la justice et en gros ils savent
pas quelle sauce ils vont être mangés
quand vous attendez quand vous êtes
libre que vous passez le 24 janvier que
vous savez pour certains d'entre eux
vous avez 14 ans au dessus du crâne
c'est difficile d'évoluer quoi et ils
sont dans cette situation là alors
qu'ils ont profondément le sentiment ils
savent qu'ils ont sauté mais quelque
part paradoxalement ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir bien fait pour l'honneur d'une
gamine pour l'honneur d'une fille de 6
ans c'est ça ce qu'ils ont fait et ça
moi je peux le comprendre et donc voilà
ils sont confrontés à toutes ces
problématiques qui ne les dépassent
aussi parfois donc voilà aujourd'hui le
la maman elle est dans quel état ce
qu'elle se dit ma fille s'est fait
agressive mon mari peut-être risque des
années de prison la réponse dans la
question elle est dévastée absolument
dévastée c'est un sentiment
d'incompréhension
ils ont rien demandé ils sont
tranquilles chez eux leur vie bascule en
une soirée ils étaient heureux ils
avaient une petite fille et voilà tout
se passait bien pour eux exactement à
basculer complètement par un élément
extérieur complètement voilà ils avaient
miser rien à voir là-dedans et donc là
leur vie bas logiciel pourrait servir
c'est devenu un cauchemar c'est devenu
un cauchemar et en plus ils sont dans le
cyclone médiatico judiciaire donc pour
eux il y a rien de simple
ça va être difficile de se reconstruire
mais je vais vous dire celle qui compte
le plus c'est la petite question
elle c'est elle qui compte le plus c'est
elle qu'il faut protéger la mer
s'accroche le père s'accroche je crois
qu'ils sont animés par ce désir ils
essaient de la protéger le plus possible
de pas essayer de voilà qu'est-ce qui
lui dit fais de la réconforter bien sûr
maintenant il faut essayer d'endormir
une fille c'est simple dans sa chambre
imagine qu'un agresseur va arriver à
2h30 du matin à son domicile c'est ça
qui est terrible et c'est ça qui doit
affronter et c'est ça que le procure la
République quelque part un peu oublié
lorsqu'il a fait les premières
déclarations qui étaient les siennes
on peut pas juger le gars avant le père
le père va être jugé avant le mec
il a raison
incroyable ça veut dire non plus il va
être jugé le 24 janvier le père et le le
nom qui a agressé la petite il va être
du géant il y a pas de date
avant le coupable
après nous les avocats on peut demander
des renvois on va voir faudra procureur
a considérer que la situation était
simple elle l'est pas effectivement mais
est-ce que c'est vraiment le débat au
fond parce qu'il y a une vraie question
c'est est-ce que ça change quelque chose
qui soit le véritable coupable ou pas
si on doit condamner l'acte en lui-même
vous avez raison